wenn dir dieses gefühl wenn man so weiß
wo es gerade ungesund aber es hat sich
fast genauso viele nicht hält was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut das video das jetzt
gleich sehen
das habe ich schon fertig aufgenommen
und das hier muss ich jetzt im
nachhinein noch einmal aufnehmen ich
habe es eigentlich schon mal aufgenommen
allerdings aus versehen wieder gelöscht
weil da irgendwie ein bisschen zeit
zwischen lag und keine ahnung ich habe
meine sdk in formatiert dann war das
werk auf jeden fall habe ich ja
wahrscheinlich habt ihr schon gelesen
ein neues 24 stunden experimente kommen
wir jetzt jede woche dienstags
normalerweise um 19 uhr diese woche
musste ich einmal um einen tag
verschieben ich hoffe ist kein problem
von euch ich habe letztes mal ein
kommentar gelesen ja manchmal 24 schon
kino essen habe ich so noch nicht
gesehen
das machen wir heute und ja dabei
wünsche euch viel spaß eine bock habt
auf weitere 24 schon videos last noch
nach oben da und schreibt mir gerne
ideen in die kommentare
für nächste woche ob ich auch schon echt
coole idee heute war es war so ein
bisschen trashiger sah ich mal und
natürlich auch ungesund keine frage aber
ich wünsche euch viel spaß und wir
fangen wir schon ein bisschen später
auch viertel nach zehn ist aber gar kein
problem ich habe ja das ist immer noch
offen
das heißt ich kann jetzt los fahren und
mir ein paar sachen besorgen ich habe
mich zu sein gar keinen plan ob ich da
oder was ich da alles finden werde weil
natürlich gibt es nach chips und popcorn
ich versuche aber mal teilt sich jetzt
bei dem ersten kino nur das bekam auch
noch ein und ab zu fahren damit ich also
ein bisschen mehr auswahl habe ich ja
schon gesagt natürlich ist so etwas sehr
sehr ungesund aber wir machen es einfach
mal
ich bin gespannt und metzger leute was
man ja auch sagen muss um meine haare
wir sind ganz schön sondern geklebt ihr
könnt ja gern jetzt mal irgendwann
betrag in die kommentare schreiben
von dem er glaubt so teuer wie das ganze
weil man kennt es ja kinos verlange für
ein kleines popcorn plus kleine cola
irgendwie 10 euro das finde ich ja
wirklich ebenso frechheit natürlich muss
ich so was auf
ganz klar aber für ein kleines popcorn
bloß kleine kohler 10 euro ich weiß ja
ich tippe auf 890 euro für das ganze
video
obwohl na ja ist denn weniger sagen wir
30 maximal 30 eigentlich könnte ich mich
jetzt spontan auch noch in vier sätzen
oder ich meinen wir nicht eh schon da
bin ich muss mich erst mal die filme
angucken so das legen wir die einzigen
filme die hier noch laufen
ich wollte sie eigentlich fühlen aber
ich hatte absolut keine angst dass ich
irgendwie schon runter gefallen
leute ich habe keinen kann wo ich das
popcorn hin tun soll das du heut nix
raus stellt heute ich musste jetzt
einfach noch 52 paar gewinnzahlen dafür
dass wir fünf minuten stand auf jeden
fall habe ich bis jetzt nur die popcorn
dann hier was zu trinken ich wollte
keine cola nehmen wenn ich mir so
ungesund bei vorgekommen eigentlich
wollte ich apfelsaft er war irgendwie
leer
dieses bike geworden ich weiß auch nicht
so das gesündeste und nachos habe ich
auch schon mal also das standard zeigt
ich falls allerdings vielleicht weiter
das gut dass ich wohnen können gibt es
viele kilos und mal gucken ob in dem
kino das da hinten irgendwo ist ja ein
bisschen mehr auswahl ist wir hatten
nicht mehr bei den jerry's so leute
jetzt haben wir da direkt das nächste
kino das heißt irgendwie rex oder so und
ich glaube da hinten ist auch noch eins
ich bin ja irgendwie bisschen
orientierungslos gerade also wir haben
es auch schon elf wo ich hoffe da hat
noch etwas offen aber hiermit gebe ich
mich jetzt nicht so viel dass wir viel
zu wenig ich frage mich auch immer
welche menschen an einem montag als
heute montag feiern gehen so und da ist
das nächste kino filmpalast genau
zu essen gibt es ja nichts mehr weiß ob
sie irgendwo noch nie hatten leider kein
essen mehr gelaufen wie sie zurzeit
immer so verrückte menschen um so
vielleicht habe ich hier mehr
[Musik]
leute scheiße die hatten wir noch offen
aber es gab kein essen mehr also die
haben nicht der verkauf die ist hier
zumindest das an rate komplett da war
schon alles dunkel ich bin da auch so
dumm dass ich das immer so spät machen
ich mache alles einfach auf dem letzten
drücker ist aber gar kein problem wer
jetzt ihren laptops popcorn und das
sollte er das erreichen die törns habe
ich hier um viertel nach zehn gestartet
2015 also also die dass bis nächsten tag
um 22.15 und ich konnte am morgen war
jetzt habe ich so ein poken dem heißt
ich kann dir morgen hierher fahren ja
arbeitsgesetz macht zurück nach hause
das ist ja noch die menschen hier becken
[Musik]
endlich geschafft es ist so ein auf und
diesen ganzen müll hin zu tragen auf
jeden fall ist das jetzt hier meine
einzige beute wir haben die sprite
popcorn und nachos hat alles zusammen
insgesamt ich glaube 13 euro kostet auch
hinein ist habe ich eine quittung
vergessen
sowas kann nicht mehr alles von den
steuern absetzen so leute wären jetzt 23
23 und was ich habe jetzt meinen
abschluss das ist eine mittlere portion
soweit ich weiss und die ja probiere ich
erstmal brauche ich liebe ja natürlich
das ist ja jetzt in folge von entspannt
zug nur entspannt ist mir morgen geht
bei ganz wichtig das einzige was den
morgen früh haben ist im popcorn
überhaupt konnte frühstück warum
eigentlich nicht davon jetzt werden wir
noch entspannt und ein paar fotos
bearbeitet immer instagram weil ich da
ja aktuell jeden tag ich habe einen
schönen stoffen haben jeden tag
wenigsten 165 tagen ein foto deswegen
recht parks macht das sehr gerne ich
weiß alex w
das sieht hier aber gar nicht so viel
aus aber ich bin wirklich sowas von saab
einen abschuss passiert ja öfter mal
dass ein land plötzlich schlecht ist
aber alles cool wenn ihr dieses gefühl
wenn man so weist es gerade um gesund
aber es ist halt so trotzdem ist genau
so fühle ich mich ich habe auch gar
keine ahnung ob ich das jetzt hier so
stehen lassen oder ob ich das halt im
kühlschrank packe weil ich meine alles
außer das getränk hat ja eigentlich
nichts im kühlschrank verlor also gute
nacht ich freue mich schon auf morgen
früh auf das popcorn
dann fahren aber auch schnell mal die
stadt muss man kommt immer die kinos
aufmachen und dann hoffe ich dass auch
noch was anderes gibt so leute einen
wunderschönen guten morgen ich hoffe ihr
habt alle gut geschlafen
das ding ist
ich war mir unsicher gäste ich nahm mir
unsicher wegen den saucen deswegen hab
ich die nazis auf jeden fall im
kühlschrank gestellt und das popcorn
dann halt auch ja wenn ich mal gespannt
also abgeneigt davon bin ich jetzt nicht
[Musik]
alles merkel auf jeden fall noch so wie
gestern
deswegen kleiner tipp wenn pop mann
nicht hart werden soll passt einfach im
kühlschrank oder ob jetzt muss ich ja
auch sagen und völlig durch so leute es
ist jetzt schon 13 30 und ich habe jetzt
folgendes vorgebracht und ein bisschen
wie google und mir ist aufgefallen die
meisten kinos dies ergibt die kenne ich
gar nicht sie sind dann auch irgendwie
mehr so für ältere und so keine ahnung
auf jeden fall habe ich ein kino
gefunden das wohl hot dogs hat ist zwar
ein bisschen außerhalb was ich da noch
so finde aber das ist jetzt extrem
wichtig weil dieses scheiß popcorn bis
jetzt zwar schon zur hälfte leer aber
irgendwie ist das extrem trocken und
mein ganzes zimmer ich dass wir danach
also wie man als los ich habe glaube ich
15 minuten weg vom keine ahnung ihr
könnt ihr in der zeit so gern wir
kommentieren was als nächstes also
nächste woche dran kommen soll
bin gespannt und gefahrlos so leute ich
bin jetzt gerade noch mal in die stadt
gefahren
und habe ihr sohn ben jerry's gekauft in
diesem kino das gestern zu war es hat
sechs euro bekommen die sieben euro
gekostet leute ich habe es wirklich hot
dogs gekriegt ich habe auch eigentlich
so halter von gut möchte ich es nur muss
das eis ist jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
halb geschmolzen ist habe ich schon vor
einer halben stunde gekauft
nun geht eigentlich hofft jetzt geht's
erst mal schnell nach hause leute ich
muss ich ein bisschen beeilen weil ich
habe gerade das tanja hier gemacht und
ja die kammer hatte ich kein auto mehr
das ist wirklich eine sehr leckere
kombination und auch wirklich gesund und
das empfinde ich natürlich auch allen
leuten die jetzt gerade hier zu gucken
ist auf jeden fall etwas sehr nice es
was natürlich auch den den allen leuten
die die sendung sehen zu empfehlen ist
halt wenn die auf abtrennen wollen
als ich hier bei den letzten zwei wochen
jetzt rachel ist gemacht das ist auf
jeden fall die wir finden bis jetzt am
besten ich weiß gar nicht warum er
überhaupt so hier wird hier noch die
nachos draußen schon wieder dunkel was
ich noch gar nicht erzählt hat ich hab
noch nie mein leben zuvor
dieses budget also ich hab noch nie bei
den jewels eis gegessen hat sich jetzt
vielleicht erst ein bisschen komisch an
aber ist halt wirklich so alle sagen ja
mal das soll sogar schmecken deswegen
ich bin mal gespannt ich habe hier gibt
es anscheinend auch verschiedene sorten
cookie daher wird es gehofft hier ist
ein weg vorbei weil zwar keine dafür
mehr sondern nur noch die neuigkeit
gleich auch mal die kalorien
zusammenzählen die ich dann gegessen
habe ich glaube es war schon extrem
ungesund ungesunder geht doch eigentlich
gar nicht mehr oder weniger falsche die
letzten challenge noch nicht gesehen
haben sondern stunden gefängnis essen
war eigentlich von entspannten stunden
astronauten essen täglich das hier war
das geilste nicht erst jetzt erst mal
zeigen wie viele davon schaffen
leute wir haben heute schon mittwoch ich
bin fertig gewesen gestern keine ahnung
ich war gestern abend dann relativ das
habe ich jetzt sagen werden auch
kartoffeln also ich mache mir abends
weil ich kann ja nicht so gut kochen
einfach manchmal kartoffeln weil ich
sehr sehr gerne kartoffeln es trotzdem
jetzt noch ein kleines resümee und ich
habe ja gesagt ich möchte einmal die
kalorien zusammenzählen und natürlich
hier unten auch noch mal das
was ich aus zu geben habe also wir
hatten im kino direkt am anfang die
nachschuss das popcorn und die spiders
war insgesamt 13 euro 80 am nächsten tag
hatten wir da noch das hot dog 94 und
dass ben jerry's für sieben euro
oder was immer ich habe leider keine
quittung darüber aber ich meine es waren
sieben euro ich habe einfach bezahlt und
nicht genau kann ich mich nicht mehr
daran erinnern
auf jeden fall ist jetzt der endbetrag
und jetzt rechne ich mir noch schnell
die kalorien zusammen ich muss
allerdings sagen dass ben jerry's habe
ich nur zur hälfte gegessen da war ich
wohl gestern also ich glaube das ist ja
auch eine woche portion ich hatte auch
eine nummer kleiner nehmen können aber
gut ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen
gegoogelt und den genauen wert an
kalorien kann ich jetzt glaube ich nicht
ermitteln wir haben einmal das popcorn
das waren ungefähr 145 gramm das sind
750 kalorien plus dann hatten wir eine
mittlere position nachos laut dieser
internetbeitrag ist eine kleine portion
mit käse dip circa 530 kalorien mit 430
kalorien ich hatte beide ich hatte beide
tipps habt ihr allerdings nicht ganz
aufgegeben deswegen würde ich jetzt auch
einfach mal mit 700 kalorien rechnen
hätte ich eigentlich sogar merck gedacht
weil abschuss fühlen sich immer so um
gesunde an ein normales hot dog hat
ungefähr 467 kalorien
wobei ich sagen muss dass das was ich
hatte wirklich groß war
deswegen würde ich hier jetzt auch mal
optimistisch mit sagen wir 600 kalorien
rechten 100 milliliter sprite sind 37
kalorien das heißt wir haben insgesamt
370 und zum schluss haben wir noch dass
ben jerry's eis mit 270 kalorien pro 100
gramm die packung hat 425 gramm das
heißt wir haben 270 mal 4,25 gleich
durch zwei weil ich habe ja noch die
hälfte gegessen 573 kalorien also
insgesamt 2 1993 also knapp 3000
kalorien ist jetzt gar nicht mal so
extrem viel ich glaube normalerweise
brauchen erwachsene 2200 am tag
korrigiert mich gerne auf jeden fall war
es eine witzige challenge und es hat
spaß gemacht das war echt entspannt und
lecker gerne wieder
das ist von mir ich wollte morgen auch
schon einen schönen joggen ab kilometer
und von daher alles cool hat rein